I hope you didn't get tripped up by this question. The answer is a fast ADH
and a slow ALDH2. Think about it. A fast ADH means we're going to go right
from ethanol to acetaldehyde. We're going to have
a quick buildup of acetaldehyde. I'm going to slow
ALDH2 or reduced activity ALDH2, means that we're
going to be really slow at moving from acetaldehyde
to acetic acid. So it's going to be the biggest buildup here. Now the opposite
of that, a slow ADH and a
fast ALDH2 would actually minimize the acetaldehyde intermediate
and have the least severe alcohol flush. Whereas having a fast ADH and a fast
ALDH2 or having both enzymes have a
reduced activity would be somewhere in the middle.